day two of the republican national
convention it kicks off later today it's
the first day
the first day rather was about
presenting a very different image of
america
from the one that the democrats
portrayed last week
republicans praised president trump as
the only solution
to this country's problems ben tracy is
following the convention from the white
house ben good morning
gail good morning so yesterday after he
was officially nominated president trump
said the only way he's going to lose the
election
is if it's rigged then last night we
heard what many republicans think will
happen to the country
if he doesn't win the republican
national convention began with the
president's version of how he views his
handling of the coronavirus
one leader took decisive action to save
lives
president donald trump but the president
downplayed the threat of the virus for
months
it will go away just stay calm in an
appearance with essential workers last
night he made a similar claim
we just have to make this china virus go
away and it's happening
but there is no evidence the virus is
going away
on sunday alone there were around 38 000
new cases
the convention promised an optimistic
and uplifting message but it did not
always sound that way
trump is the bodyguard of western
civilization trump was elected to
protect our families
from the vengeful mob that seeks to
destroy our way of life
they want to destroy this country
and everything that we have fought for
and hold dear
they want to steal your liberty your
freedom
they want to control what you see and
think and believe so that they can
control
how you live that warning was echoed
several times including by the
mccloskeys who were charged with
unlawful use of a weapon
after they drew their guns on peaceful
protesters outside their home in st
louis earlier this summer no matter
where you live
your family will not be safe in the
radical democrats
america the president's eldest son
donald trump jr
vigorously defended his father if
democrats cared for the forgotten men
and women of our country
they'd do exactly what president trump
is doing
as did his former u.s ambassador to the
u.n nikki haley
donald trump has always put america
first
and he has earned four more years as
president
republican senator tim scott played off
the convention night theme
land of promise our family went from
cotton
to congress in one lifetime
scott argued the gop offers the best
hope of making the american dream
a reality make no mistake
joe biden and kamala harris want a
cultural
revolution a fundamentally different
america
if we let them they will turn our
country
into a socialist utopia
now tonight first lady melania trump is
set to deliver her speech from the newly
renovated rose garden here
at the white house as for the biden
campaign it did release a statement
calling the first night of the rnc
dark and divisive fear-mongering with no
plan for combatting coronavirus
anthony ben thank you